[Music]
life in these makeshift tant is tough
but refugees who call them home say the
hardest months are yet to
come when the Sai lead Coalition began
bombing Yemen Bish Ahmed fled and was
placed in Marazzi refugee camp in jibuti
with her five
children these tents and steel units she
says are worse than
ovens summer temperatures here exceed
50°
C she has been in this camp for 6 years
now she wants to leave because she says
her children would have no future if
they
stay there are a lot of problems the
things in me and around me died I lost
family members in Yemen the others are
in prison I want a new life for me and
my kids her sister lives in the United
States and she hopes to one day live in
the US near her but other migrants are
arriving in this country too the fear of
a war between the houthis and the US is
forcing people in Yemen to find safety
by crossing the Babel Mand up Street to
reach Djibouti also there are Ethiopians
fleeing conflicts and poverty in their
country those from Yemen are trying to
get to Western countries while ethopians
are aiming for Gulf
States these migrants are fing conflict
and poverty in Ethiopia they're heading
to Yemen hoping to reach Saudi
Arabia civil engine near msan asafa is
from the Ethiopia's amhara region drones
bombed his house his family sold what
was left to afford his journey that can
take up to three
months he walked for days to get his
last destination the town of ubuk before
boarding a small boat to cross the Babel
Mand
Street we left our country and I don't
know what will happen to me I don't know
if I will live be arrested or killed we
are now in jibou close to the the I want
to go to Saudi Arabia and find a job
every year thousands of Ethiopians like
mcana attempt at dangerous migration
route from the Horn of Africa crossing
the Gulf of Adan through Yemen into
Saudi
Arabia dozens have been killed by border
guards or while trying to cross the sea
on small unstable
boats exhausted from a monthlong
challenging Journey with little food and
water these migrants hope they won't
meet a similar end
Al
jazer
jibuti make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer